T
>>ANNENG
DEAT LED TO A
PLANE CRH INASY D
PASSENGER'S .
[ BLEEP ]
AND FLEW STS ENGINE
AOUY
TRAIIS'RE S NEAR
IN F WORTH.
THE TWO INECTED E WAS BADLY BURD
IN LAKE
IT DIDN'T HIAN
DIRECTLY ANDY ON THE
GROUND WAS HURT.
Y A VE ALARMING TUGET MOTHIS, O
SCHIAVO IS TELL US ABOUTS
INCRLE VIDEO IS THIS WE KNOWTH
PILO.SOMETHING TH OOKOUTOR.BUT
SEOK, IT IS
STUNNING.
S
AN HPFES, THE TECOLLECTING DATAR
FO 2ATICLY
T INCREASE% OVER 2020.
SORATIY
INCREASINGBUT YOU DON'OFTES.
THEY JUST HAA PERFST  THESE
WEAGAINST THEM.
EY WERE IN A SINGLE ENGINE
TRAINER ON APPROACH  LITERALLY
OT ONE THACAN COMING
GLID W
TH C
E --IDE BETTER WITH
AND THEY V GROUND.
OE WINGAD
Y THINBUATELY NO
DIED ALTHOUGH THEY ARERT.>> RIG.
THAT YOU DIDN'
ASH.BOE GROUND WAS
INPANTSERIOUERE WAS SOME DAMAGEE
SERIOUS PROBLEM.THIS
AND SOD DEEDN UNPUNISHED.
DANGER TOAIRCRANDIRPORTS.
ANE S TH
UD TSTILL SEEHENDFILLS, BODIEO.
ANWH
BIAY HAV BEEN
L YET.
THE IDERIN
AND ANOTHE